um do you have an old only fans
do I yeah I mean it seems like it would
make perfect sense to have like an
uncensored version of Dan bilzerian's
Instagram that you got to pay for in
only fans yeah I made one but I just
like I don't know man I felt [__]
like cheesy posting on there and then
also like I didn't really want to like
expose the girls because there was like
we have some crazy [__] that you know
always happens that like I mean honestly
like I can't post 90 of the [__] that
happens right girls are running around
naked you know you can't do that you
can't have suggested you can't have hand
bras you can't you know obviously
suggested what's suggested I think like
like like
yeah it looks like something even if it
you know it is happening or it looks
like it's happening you know like
Instagram got pretty serious really
really pussified man yeah they did and
so I think that's one of the reasons why
only fans doing so well that and you
know guys are just way lonelier than I
ever thought they were
you know it's a crazy thing man like I
remember when they came with this
concept only fans and I'm like so
you're telling me that the guy's gonna
pay to talk to a girl who's not [__]
I'm like you're [__] [__] man I'm
like I didn't even know that that's what
it was I thought you had to pay on a
like per post basis you have to pay to
unlock an image well you could pay some
chat as well yeah there's there's like
different things like originally it was
like you subscribed to their page and
then you like pay in the chat and then
like the unlock pictures there's like
you know a lot of different ways to skin
the cat I think but like isn't that just
like a strip club
kind of I mean it's like a virtual like
online you know I think she likes me
dude and you know the funny thing is
they'll really [__] kicker of this
whole goddamn deal is most of the
[__] people that these guys are
talking to or other dudes or [__] old
ladies that's not the chick boy I was
doing it for Priya I was texting
30 grand on this month
are you allowed to say that I don't
[__] know
like a template of like already like
phrases that she wanted me to reply with
and like like they'd be sending me dick
pics and like have like a horde so it's
like oh show me something
yeah
yeah yeah oh my God
that's the norm like for you to actually
be talking the chick is very rare I bet
back in the day of like uh the 1900 yeah
I mean that kind of [__] that might be
chicks but but not the ones in the
pictures yeah no nowadays you're
probably talking to like an AI bot
that's like not even [__] hey I
bought it
they basically like ask the questions
and then you have a bunch of like you
know their answers to the most commonly
asked questions and then yeah I bought
just figure it out here's the thing like
when you have you know two million
followers or whatever the [__] these
girls have how can you you know respond
to all these people so it's like they
basically pay the agencies like 20 25
and then those people answer around the
clock and then they just make more money
you know know they're paying out a piece
but they're making more like net at the
end of the day because somebody's
responding 24 7. yeah it's margin on
that like who cares if it's just the
volume is [__] insane that's the
thing and the girls are lazy too so
they'll just like forget to text or like
that was one of the most surprising
things to me about the only fan stuff is
these girls be making like real money I
mean like 50 000 a month 40 000 a month
and they would actually get lazy to me
it's like if I'm making that kind of
bread I want to make 70. I want to make
80. I don't know like how far can we
take this right this is a [__] cash
cow and let's cash in now these chicks
are like well I bought my purse I got my
shoes you know I'm a sugar daddy's
paying my car like I don't really need
to work so I'm not gonna work instead of
like let's [__] make all the money
while we can because we literally have a
three year shelf life before we [__]
you know are not attractive anymore
whatever you know it's like what did and
and a lot of them don't realize they
have to pay taxes on that did you ever
have an issue with like killing it a lot
of money and like the learning curd of
like paying the tax man right away or I
got [__] so so one of the reasons why
I'd never go to house in California is
because of California taxes my problem
was I made a lot of the [__] poker
money in California so one of the things
people don't realize like if you're in
you know
I don't know man Puerto Rico USVI I
don't know if you're aware of those tax
you know things that's why the Paul
Brothers yeah they're paying four
percent is it literally four percent on
all of their [__] so representation
without taxation right so they don't
have a governor there because they don't
pay taxes or there's no Senator
representing them because they don't pay
taxes I don't know what the what like
the reason is but I do know like Puerto
Rico is like that it's U.S territory
USVI is like that and they pay four
percent and it's not and that's like on
cap gains that's on their income that's
on everything so it's a mass my buddy my
buddy saved 75 million bucks in one year
you know what I mean just sure so it's
like and you don't have to live there
the whole year it's like six months or
the majority six months in one day I'll
do a trip first and then the second year
I think it's just more time there than
in the US you could spend four months in
Europe you know for the summer then
spend four months in a day there and
then three months and [__] 29 days
you know in California you're fine so if
you're making a lot of money and you're
doing it like online and there's [__]
no better [__]
um but anyways the point that I'm
getting to is like even if you're in
that tax loophole
every dollar that you make in California
pays California tax so if you are a
[__] like
I don't even know the Texas [__]
teams whatever Florida teams say you're
a [__] Tampa Bay Buccaneer and you
play a game in uh La you pay California
taxes on that game and every game that
you play so if you play yeah it's [__]
up man it's like the craziest thing ever
well because because remember I was
looking to move to Nevada or looking to
move somewhere because just to buy a
house and and I was talking I've talked
to maybe five or six accountants and
they're like all your money comes from
California so there's no tax breaks on
it because I was trying to get creative
with it and you know some people set up
a thing in Wyoming or Delaware it's like
where do you work and I'm like well the
llc's are registered in California and
they're like yeah okay man that's crazy
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude